all right we're going to turn now to our
series kindness 101 with Steve Hartman
in it we share stories built around
kindness and character and the people
who have mastered those qualities
today's lesson positivity Steve and his
kids show us how one family's positive
outlook in tough times opened a window
to a world they could never have
imagined
good morning this is Merrill my
soon-to-be nine-year-old daughter here
to help me teach a lesson on positivity
I met at the dictionary desk can you
define this word yes I can real
positivity is the practice of extracting
a sunny takeaway from a not so good
situation yeah positivity isn't being
happy because you won the lottery that's
easy it's not too easy no not winning
the lottery but being happy if you win
the lottery yes winning the lottery is
going to be something that everyone is
excited about positivity is really like
you have to take a bad situation and
look at it yeah positivity is finding
joy in the negative strange as that
sounds correct and this is a very
important tool to have in your tool belt
so let's look now in our library of life
lessons and pull down a tale that
illustrates the power of positivity
aside from immediate family no one was
allowed in the house to see
three-year-old Quinn Waters of Weymouth
Massachusetts
and more importantly Quinn wasn't
allowed out
we basically keep him in a bubble just
as a precaution even a cold a common
cold could be something that will bring
him back into the hospital parents
jarlith and Tara say Quinn's natural
immunity was temporarily wiped out after
he got a stem cell transplant to treat
his brain cancer
[Music]
fortunately the kid is a fighter and he
kept a mostly positive attitude do you
want to drink or anything dude
but it's still stunk he sees all of this
happening and he knows he's stuck inside
and there would be days Days When Quinn
was literally pounding to get out
unfortunately staring out a window is a
poor substitute for walking out a door
Quinn's connection to the outside world
has been limited to whoever passes by
which hasn't been all that limiting
actually it started off with family
members like come to the window
then the neighbors started showing up to
entertain
the police caught wind and pretty soon
top-notch performers were just showing
up on Quinn's front lawn it's turned
into like a Vaudeville stage out there
yeah the window kind of became his
window to the world you know it got so
you never knew what might happen by one
minute it could be a dog parade
the next a team of Irish Step dancers
everyone brought together by word of
mouth and a will to help Quinn get
better
which his parents say did start
happening it's the positive energy from
all these people that we believe has
gotten him through his his sickness you
know
you can never repay you know
just maybe
pay it forward you know
being indebted has never felt so
fortunate
come on without you come on within
you'll not seat up and like the mighty
quick
[Music]
[Applause]
Quinn's parents Tara and jarlith join us
now hello hello hi first of all you've
got to tell us how Quinn's doing oh
Quinn is doing really well he relapsed
in 2021
um but since that time he received
radiation and he's been stable playing
t-ball now with his friends he's in
school he looks great hair I've never
seen hair on the boy yes he's got a
great flow going he's got the hockey
hair we call this what struck me most
after our first visit was the fact that
you seem to think that positivity would
actually make him better I don't think
it can all be just modern medicine I
think you have to have a positive
outlook on things so you think that
thoughts can change reality 100
absolutely yeah it'll change the outcome
and I think it'll change your outlook as
you go on anything and has the grass
grown back on your yard grass will never
be the same
well thank you so much for joining us
we've been positively thrilled to have
you
thank you
a really good lesson there and a
reminder that often when one door closes
another window opens we'll see you next
time until then stay kind
[Music]
we will do exactly that Meryl it's so
great to see him I know it is so good
about it and doing well I I just love
these pieces the the family dynamic
between uh the Hartman family the
Harvard family is just so good yeah
they're a lesson in all things goodness
all of them it's great thank you Steve
and Meryl and of course Emmett